hallo mein name ist programm liebe
freunde ich darf euch heute recht
herzlich willkommen heißen zu einem
neuen video auf einem kanal in dem ihr
die autobahnpolizei simulator 2 spielen
los melde dich am empfang an ok ich
glaube dass das in der empfang ist
momente hallo was kann ich für sie tun
ich möchte zu herrn becker ich eröffne
ihnen die tür zum chef geht es die
treppe rauf und dann links ok sehr gut
eröffnet mir die tür das heißt wir gehen
hoch und einfach mal von der tür
erschlagen werden hiervon es auf jeden
fall roland becker dagegen einfach mal
rein
sie sind also herr schmidt richtig ist
es sind zehn minuten zu spät
bried zeitverschiebung ledigen sie ihre
aufgaben korrekt und spielen sie nicht
den helden marine hätten wir beide keine
probleme bekommen schönherr standen
verstanden und nun willkommen in der
truppe da geht jetzt meine uniform nun
umziehen ich ziehe meine uniform hahn
und herr schmidt sie sehen ja aus wie
komplett neuer spricht mit hans hast du
bist also der frischling nee ich bin
hans dein partner freut mich dich
kennenzulernen mich ja auch mich ja wir
haben ein auto genug zeit zu reden lasst
uns loslegen
einsatzwagen steht im hof ich habe zwar
keinen einsatzwagen unten im hof
allerdings habe ich ein bundespolizist
bei der wohnung
hallo das ist simon und simon hat im
gegensatz mehr was erreicht im leben ja
du warst ja schon mal bei uns im aus und
fortbildungszentrum in eschwege
und ja das könnte man dieses jahr leider
nicht fortsetzen aufgrund der aktuellen
situation deswegen habe ich gedacht ich
komme einfach mal zu dir ja genau wir
sind auch beide selbstverständlich chor
oder negativ getestet haben dennoch eine
transparente trennwand zwischen uns
aufgebaut und ich habe direkt eine
allererste frage was genau ist denn der
unterschied zwischen jetzt
beispielsweise der bundespolizei und der
landespolizei also die normale polizei
die kennst du ja in jedem bundesland und
wir haben zusätzlich einfach noch
sonderaufgaben also zum beispiel
grenzschutz bahnpolizei luftsicherheit
damit den urlaub fliegt oder so jetzt
gerade nicht aber wenn du
dafür ist das letzte was du siehst es
ein bundespolizist das erste was du
siehst sehr krass verschiedene
aufgabenbereiche auf semmel
abwärtswandler aufgaben quasi natürlich
auch küstenwache zum beispiel so
bundespolizei see ist teil der
küstenwache aber ganz wichtig auch
ausland wir sind eine absolut
internationale polizei wir haben 2500
kolleginnen und kollegen im ausland in
183 ländern der welt ich weiß nicht mehr
so viele länder gibt
weil es in der vergangenheit schon so
gut funktioniert hat haben wir eine
taskforce aus autobahn polizei und zoll
gegründet die seine das ziel den
menschenschmuggel zu stoppen und die
hintermänner dingfest zu machen wir
suchen ein lkw mit diesem logo auf
zurzeit auf den autobahnen in dieser
gegend befinden soll wir hoffen so die
drahtzieher schnappen zu können ja gibt
es noch irgendwelche fragen nein doch
dann los ja dann gar kein problem für
alter gibt es solche task forces
wirklich heißt das dann auch so
taskforce heißt es jetzt nicht unbedingt
aber gemeinsame ermittlungsgruppen wo
dann auch der zoll mit dazu kommt oder
eben natürlich die landespolizei die
kripo es wird es perfekt auf
bundespolizei passen also ihr haben
tatsächlich gerade in unserem 30
kilometer bereich wo wir diese bin
grenzfahndung machen genau solche fälle
im wunderland der einreise und
einschleusen von ausländern das ist
genauso zuständigkeit das ist schon
realistisch das ist auch realistisch das
ist relativ auch mein arm umfang wie
viel kölsch shops mit seiner intel kommt
drauf an wie viel kilo sehen 30-40 keine
ahnung müsste man mal ausprobieren was
dann hier welche da wäre doch mal eine
challenge später jetzt müssen wir den
zielort erreichen das heißt wir laufen
jetzt hier raus und hier raus und ort
wir sind türen alter mein größtes
hindernis als bundespolizist wenn
einfach türen
die muss ich runter egal wir leben noch
dass sie auch sagt abgezogen
wir sind da eine regelrechte gerät den
schnappe ich mir ja den stadtbus schnell
hinterher
heute wenn du interesse jetzt an
gesungen wird muss ich jetzt rechtsklick
jetzt muss ich hier ich weiß ihm aus
wird mal einen taten sowie schnell
drücken aufspringen sagt weiter es aus
gewicht sehr gut und jetzt colaflasche
wir haben ihnen sie uns schnee den
laderaum des lkws öffnen dann schnell
befreien die menschen schnell zurück
hier hin
ich befreie euch ladies and gentlemen
okay ich habe die menschen da jetzt
befreit habe aber dennoch ein paar
fragen zu dieser mission ja ich auch
diese andere person die wir da jetzt
gerade mit der cola flasche beworfen
haben wird so die allein verfolgen oder
eher als team die würde die nerven gehen
also man sollte immer zusammenbleiben zu
zweit ja manchmal lässt sich nicht
vermeiden dass man sich irgendwie mal
aufteilen muss das will ich jetzt gar
nicht so aber grundsätzlich sollte man
da immer zusammenbleiben
du bist einfach so ohne team einfach los
wir haben tatsächlich in vielen lkws
oder aufzügen oder was auch immer
tatsächlich viele migranten die einreise
nach deutschland
und die sind teilweise ja wirklich tage
dann einfach da drin in diesem lkws und
dann müsstest du jetzt quasi sofort den
rettungswagen rufen je nachdem wie so
lange wie die da drin waren
und dann die arbeit eigentlich erst
richtig los wird dann wird das verfahren
eigentlich erst eröffnet wer steckt
dahinter
wieso sind die da drin wer hat das geld
kassiert und so weiter und so fort
wir sind wieder zurück an unserer
polizeistation angekommen natürlich
perfekt eingepackt man kennt ihn und
jetzt kommen die verdächtigen mit raus
und mit auf die wache
da sitzt du blödmann dass er sein leben
gehören so so herr grunwald wir haben
einiges zu besprechen jahren sie zur
import export firma sternberg die
adresse zum büro finden sie im internet
da sitzt mein chef marcel sternberg der
sich gerade eine goldene nase verdient
das ging aber schnell
alles klar der typ hat einfach direkt
gesprochen
schön sie zu sehen anhand der guten
vorarbeit die wir hier alle zusammen
geleistet haben wollen wir jetzt den
menschenschmuggel ring endgültig
zerschlagen falls es zu einer auto
verfolgung kommt haben wir unseren
hubschrauber in der luft
wir wollen ganz sicher gehen dass wir
den kern schnappen
ich fahre wieder und ich bei meinem rudi
dann mal los okay wir fahren wieder
zusammen mal haben los geht's erst mal
müssen unsere uniform auch diese tür
alter irgendwann schraube ich dir noch
raucht jetzt geht es nämlich ab jetzt
geht's ab mit helikopter wir sind
angekommen meine lieben freunde hier ist
der einsatzort und hallo herr steinberg
würden sie gern festnehmen dass ein büro
locker nach oben gemacht wenn er hier
der kopf ist von irgendwas was man muss
immer mit fahrschulen von 15 sekunden
später sogar angezeigt
hallo so ganz schnell wieder nach unten
wir nehmen das natürlich selbst
wahrscheinlich den fahrstuhl eine stunde
später einfach entspannter müssen wir
nicht laufen das wahrscheinlich nie so
appel oder wie viele punkte soll nicht
aufziehen machen wir alle ganz kurz gut
also erstmal einparken das war sehr gut
perfekt du hast dich quasi angekündigt
und hast schon mal am gebäude angeklopft
und hallo gesagt dadurch den fahrstuhl
genutzt super immer machen also nicht
nichts machen so jetzt geht's los selig
ob da ist unterwegs bei der lieben
freunde da würd ich gern mit fliegen
gekommen die polizei davor dass der
schwarze ist wie oh wir lernen uns im
nächsten leben schnell ich weiß nicht
wie ich den stoppen soll soll ich denn
jetzt kaputt fahren also wenn ich jetzt
ruhiger bundespolizist wäre ich würde so
machen also abdrängen geht gar nicht das
ist halt so eine sache weil du hast
tatsächlich auch wenn das ein straftäter
ist du hast trotzdem für jeden menschen
mit dem tod zu tun haben auch eine
verantwortung deswegen versucht mir
quasi das was vorher passiert das zu
vermeiden und die frage wie statisch zu
halten
ja das wird auf keinen fall so ablaufen
erst mal reden
ein bundespolizist
so sei mit einer helikopter mission und
apropos helikopter meine lieben freunde
habe ich auch noch was vorbereitet
wohlig zwei hubschrauber simulator
hallo zusammen heute steht bislang
nichts besonderes an
okay da kannst du zunächst auf der wache
bleiben bis du einen einsatzbefehl von
mir erhältst du so das war's auch schon
dann mal aller art an die arbeit ja
welche
ich habe ja anscheinend nichts zu tun
haben ich mein körper tirols wo 40 höhe
oder bin ich okay so jetzt geht sie mich
los hier würde die mitfliegen
ich bin da hinten ist das ziel hat so
ein bundespolizist erst mal verflogen
sorry navi hat nicht funktioniert im
netz
[Musik]
ich hab die maximale flughöhe
überschnitten
hallo zusammen das ist ja gestern nicht
so gut gelaufen aber lass dich dadurch
nicht entmutigen
ja da hat man gesehen ich bin jetzt
nicht so der der beste helikopter
flieger bei der fliegerstaffel läuft es
natürlich hoffe ich anders an oder
ja ja man muss auch sagen wir machen das
ja alles selbst dass wir haben auch die
ganzen wartungsarbeiten und so weiter
das macht alles die bundespolizei selbst
ok und natürlich die flugtechniker und
pilotinnen und piloten auch die operator
die mit drin sind jetzt die infrarot
also wärmebildkamera da unten bedienen
also quasi auch so theoretisch wenn die
person durch den wald fliegt von
wärmebild wird er dann nicht nur rehe
sehen oder so eine drei bis fünf
kilometer sind ja kein problem
drei bis fünf kilometer das sind 3000
bis 500 meter warum in erster linie
nimmt man überhaupt noch über den
helikopter also gibt es ja wirklich
etwas gesagt da müssen wir immer
helikopter benutzen oder irgendwie so
also tatsächlich ist soviel
überwachungsflüge dann können wir ganz
schnell
wir haben ja auch das ist jetzt der
kleine wir haben auch große helikopter
damit kann man wirklich relativ schnell
auch ganz so hundertschaften was die
luft verlassen heisst das ja und dann
gibt es auch wieder flüge also
bundesregierung mit kindern
bundesregierung zum beispiel minister im
zdf mit uns hast du schon heute machst
du jemanden also da ich ja selber nicht
von der fliegerstaffel bin aber ich bin
mal mit unserer spezialeinheit gsg 9 mit
geflogen
das war die haben also diesen
abgesprungen aus einem helikopter und
ich wusste nicht dass die tür offen
bleibt dann die der motor an und ich wir
sind halt auch und ist offen geblieben
und es ist schon ein komisches gefühl
weil irgendwann springt raus an
man bleibt alleine zurück kommt darauf
an ob der pilot und er nicht auch
ausgegangen ist noch das ja ich wollte
mir nichts anmerken lassen weist davor
ja vor der gsg9 alles gut
mir geht es super für die muss ja auch
auf dem bleiben am kohlekraftwerk
apparat ist was passiert
aktuelle position kommt es zu einer
menschenansammlung das wo vorher lande
ich ja aber ganz vernünftig ganz nicht
ganz vernünftig landen müssen wir davor
achtung motto aus sie möchte mutter aus
die andere richtung niveau arbeiten wie
doch junge nein hoch hoch hoch hoch
liegen jetzt einfach mal nach vorne
nein nein nein nein hoch hoch hoch hoch
hoch
oh mein gott ach guck mal hier ist die
met begrenzen können wir gar nicht in
frieden
sie endet in der infostelle
einsatzbereichen so das war's auch schon
dann mal aller art an die arbeit wie
bereits gesagt ich habe hier nichts zu
tun
[Musik]
nein
luca immer zählt die ganze zeit warten
das ist nach sport machen okay wir haben
uns hier 210 kilo hanteln ich würde
sagen wir machen einfach ein paar kerzen
gut ich habe nichts besseres zu tun auf
jeden fall freute sich da wirklich nicht
allerdings meine lieben freunde würden
wir an der stelle das heutige wieder ist
auch beenden wenn es euch gefallen hat
er das gern ein darunter video da wenn
ihr denkt ihr wird ein besserer
bundespolizist als ich auch wenn das gar
nicht geht dann könnt ihr das dieses
jahr auf jeden fall noch werden denn was
muss man dafür tun
bis 28 zweiter auf alle fälle auf der
seite kommen zur bundespolizei punkt de
registrieren und bewerben ist das wieder
ist auch vorbei